All right. How's it going everyone?
Welcome. Today you will see a new face
than what you normally see. Uh we'll
give it a couple minutes and we'll kick
it off right away.
[Music]
I'm going to do one thing. Put up some
text. Boop.
And Aaron, I think your audio and
everything should be working just fine.
>> Yeah, I think so.
All right. Are we good to go, Aaron?
>> Yeah. Let's start this.
>> I don't know if I can hear you.
>> You can't hear me?
>> Um,
>> hello. Hello.
You can't hear me? Hello?
Maybe it's my audio, but I I can't hear
you.
>> Do you guys Are you guys able to hear
Aaron? Oh, you do. Um,
let me figure something out really fast
cuz I cannot hear him. Can you try
again, Aaron?
>> Hello.
>> Let me get some headphones.
Try one more thing.
All right. Thank you guys for reporting
the issue that it's purely on my side.
All right. Uh, can you try one last
time, Aaron?
>> Hello. Hello. Hello.
>> Oh, all right. We are good to go.
>> All right. Thank you everyone for
patiently waiting. Um, we've got our new
episode of AI that works today. And, um,
I think one of the things that we really
wanted to talk about today was a couple
of new things. One is Enthropic had a
great article about how they went down
recently and I think it's just worth
diving deep into that to go understand
what happened, how does it impact you
and like how can we understand if that
sort of stuff is going to impact us
downstream in the future uh now that we
have these runtime dependencies on these
models
>> and then there's bunch of stuff that
happened on AI uh on open dev day and I
think there's some interesting stuff to
talk about there as well.
>> So I'm Vivoth. I'm one of your co-hosts
for AI that works. And normally I have
Dexter with me. Dexter has some really
cool things going on that I can't talk
about yet. So hopefully he'll talk about
it next week, but I was able to rope in
my co-founder Aaron who I think is just
as pleasant. Probably the show should
just be him and uh Dexter on instead of
me. But Aaron, you can give a brief uh
intro and background if you want.
>> Yeah, thank you. Um yeah, so VB and I
met seven years ago. Now we're doing a
company together. And before that I used
to work at AWS in EC2 and then in Prime
Video and I worked at Amazon for like
seven years and then I was like all
right I need to do a startup now and
here I am now making a programming
language song
>> which we all know is a great startup
idea.
>> Yeah, exactly. So happy to be here.
>> Cool. Um I guess let's get right into
it. Uh let's start off with um with the
entropic uh piece right away. So, I'll
I'll go ahead and screen share and we'll
kind of walk through it together.
Uh, let me get the screen share going.
Oh, yes. We'll talk about prompt
optimizers, too. I think we'll have a
fun time today.
Screen.
So, I think the first thing I want to go
talk about is this one.
So, many of you probably have seen this
uh which is Oh, interesting.
which is this article that Enthropic
wrote or maybe you haven't which was
Enthropic uh recently had a downtime or
like I guess regress quality issues in
their models and they had like three
unique bugs that I thought were really
fascinating and talked about how almost
sensitive these models are the things
that are both incredibly technical and
also really hard to understand.
So, we figured let's just talk about it.
If someone in the audience has thoughts
or questions that they want to bring up
along the way, please do that as per
normal. Uh, because we love having
>> that kind of conversation. Yes. Let me
zoom in.
>> Yeah, there we go. Perfect.
>> Um, and like one second, I'm going to
adjust my screen. I'm on a new screen
today, so it's sadly not as efficient I
normally am.
All right. Uh, is a co is the rule for a
co-host that they must have a mustache?
Um,
>> I think so. Sadly, I can't grow one. So,
I've got to I've got to find other
people that are uh that can do it.
Um, and let's just go right into the
first one. So, the really the problems
that these happen uh is that they happen
mostly at large scale systems. If you're
running a tiny model or tiny information
provider, you likely will never run into
these. But anytime we depend on these
cloud systems, our business and our
impact of quality can have a huge impact
based on exactly what these model
providers do. And the more that we can
deeply understand them, the better we
can report. Like say we see a bunch of
issues on Twitter, which I thought was
one of the most fascinating things about
what anthropic reporter here, which is
that the more issues that we see, the
better we can understand is it a
prompting issue, is it a model
versioning issue, or is it a core infra
issue under the hood? or once we know
what to diagn
>> the worst case it's a compiler issue.
>> Yeah, the worst case a compiler issue
which is like really only not only is it
not found in the model company but based
on the core compiler to go fix as well.
But before we go into the issues, I
actually want to talk about a really
important segment that they talked about
at the very bottom
which is I think they have it somewhere
down here. Um this part and I think this
is going to be more and more true and
really applicable to every single person
being AI pipelines. Enthropic doesn't
really have too many like eval
fundamentally on their system. What they
really do is they scan for noise across
Twitter because they're so popular. they
can go do that and they're like what is
the general sentiment of vibes that is
happening when we release a new model
and if anything is going off in a really
anomal way they know for sure that they
have an issue and that's I think when
all of us think about building AI
pipelines of any kind this is one of the
most useful kind of things for all of us
to think about which is like how can we
get a latent signal here that allows us
to go track this and what's really
fascinating here is that this worked for
years for them this is the that work and
now at this current skill that they have
now it really failed because they were
able they there's some sensitive issues
that almost like conflated together at
the wrong time
>> to make it not work.
>> Part of it is really just looking at um
like at tweets and just general traffic
on social media at Amazon for example we
would just listen to like mentions of
like what are people saying
>> really?
>> Yeah. And that was that was the way that
we like measured how good the product
like obviously there were other metrics
like how how long people um stay and
like watch movies and stuff but um a big
part is just like what are the customers
saying and for this specific instance
only8% of traffic was impacted in some
cases. So you can imagine like how
difficult it must have been to find that
there was an issue. Um, and yeah, we uh
we can chat about the actual things that
happened here.
>> Cool. Let's start off with the first
one. Um, and like for people that want
to go read this whole thing, definitely
we'll link it. Uh, let me link it. Uh,
I'll link it in the email and also I
think it's in the description of the
event, but for anyone that doesn't have
it, I'll post it in the message as well.
Um, I posted in the chat thread. Um, but
the first one I thought was fascinating
was actually about like context window
routing. And a lot of people talk about
large context windows. They're like,
"Oh, let's use a million token model uh
at all times." But surprisingly, the
fundamental issue that they had here was
actually the fact that like when they
used a million million context window
for like uh I think what they said was
like smaller context requests, it
actually led to degraded performance.
Now, this is very against what a lot of
people tell you, which is like toss
everything at the biggest model at all
times.
That is not always going to lead to good
results. And I can tell you at least my
intuition about why that is the case,
but I always like to think of it in the
in the form of like software engineers.
Aaron is an amazing software engineer. I
get the pleasure of working with. But
like if I toss Aaron a bunch of nonsense
information and then with along with the
actual information that I want him to go
do, no matter how good he is,
fundamentally he has to do work to both
process the information out and also
deal with the issue of like figuring out
exactly what has to happen. So, in that
world, it would it would just be better
for him to for me to tell him exactly
what I want him to do, and he'll likely
produce a better output that I would be
super happy with at the end, no matter
how good he is.
>> Yeah, it's uh it's just like yeah, you
just have like a bigger bigger model
with a bigger context window. Um and we
can talk about exactly like the
mechanism by which people scale out
these models.
>> Oh, you want to talk about scale? Sure,
we can do that. So, like, okay, let's
talk about why why this ends up being
true. So, scallet draw. One second. I'm
going to make a little
uh let's see. Can you guys see my
scallet draw? All right, Aaron, I'm
going to send you a link to this
uh session. Copy link and I will send
this to Aaron only.
Cool.
Cool. Aaron shoveling.
>> So like why why does this kind of model
run into those kind of issues? Well,
>> let's talk about how one second. I got
to switch the chat.
>> Well, let's think about what the
mechanism doing under the hood. Like
this is at least my understanding of how
I think uh transformers work. I might be
wrong and if I am, please correct me
along the way uh for anyone that's
watching.
Fundamentally, what you do is you write
a word like the
soccer. Oops, can't spell soccer.
Soccer.
the bad soccer
player
is.
>> Yeah, I mean that's pretty good. That's
pretty good.
>> Okay, cool. Um, but like when you go do
this, what ends up happening is all the
mechanism is doing is it's taking
information
from this word and somehow trying to
bridge it all the way over into
like this word and said we're going to
move information about like best over
into soccer. And somehow this vector now
doesn't just represent soccer, it
represents both the concept of best and
soccer.
And then it's going to say then it's
going to want to translate some
information from soccer and player and
eventually
best and player also into here. So at
some point the vector represents not
just player and soccer not just best but
the idea is soccer best soccer players
represented. And as you go down this
world, the whole point is the mechanism
is just moving information between these
bridges into each other in various
birectional ways. So that at some point
the vectors represent something
meaningful. And when you decide what
token you want to generate next here,
and anyone that disagrees with this is
wrong, but um when you generate what
token you want to go generate here, you
basically are just moving information
around. So what does long context mean?
Well, this bridging is happening across
many token channels along the way.
And as you increase the context window,
the amount of effort it takes the model
to go learn how to move information
across all these vectors is different.
And it's not the same as learning what
it means to move across 10 tokens versus
moving across a million tokens. So just
because a model is capable of taking a
million tokens doesn't mean that you
actually want to go implement the full
million tokens every single time. It
might mean you still actually want to
tell the model it's like hey I want you
to ignore these parts of a do token
channel and only move information
between these vectors.
>> So I suspect what enthropic does under
the hood and I don't know this for sure
um is I suspect they have different
variants of their model. Some of which
that have the full million contacts some
of which that have shorter contacts. And
if they know what it can route to, then
they'll prefer sending to the shorter
context one if they can. Otherwise,
they'll send to a longer context one. I
suspect they have some sort of
distributed system here. Does that kind
of make sense with how you understand
these systems?
>> Basically, you um I what I'm
understanding is also that like you take
this initial context that you trained
on. So, let's say it's like 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10, right?
>> Yeah. And then they're like, "Okay, each
um vector has like each token has a
position encoding essentially."
>> Y
>> and when you expand this into 1 million
tokens, you're basically taking this
expanding it all the way. And then
basically um you you shortened the uh
the positions here. So instead of one,
you do like one 1.5, right? And then two
2.5 3.5 etc. And so like the spaces are
exactly so it's rope. Um
>> for those of you that know it's exactly
so you can look into this and this you
want to look at how rope scaling works
if you're curious.
>> Yeah.
>> But fundamentally the point is like it's
not zero cost to go and make the context
window bigger. It comes at a different
trade-off. It enables new things like
you can recognize you can give it the
whole word. You can give it like all of
Charles Dickens and say what is the one
word that is flipped
>> and it can go build that relationship
with itself.
But fundamentally what it's really doing
is like you're also coming at a
trade-off over here. So if your context
can be expressed really tursly, a
smaller model or a smaller encoding
space can do a better job of actually
understanding what you're trying to do
with less precision loss.
>> So TLDDR if you get anything out of this
just use less context and less context.
I
>> promise you your pipel pipelines will uh
be more accurate. Yeah. And that's not
to say
that's not to say um uh specifically um
like artificially reduce your context.
Use the least amount of tokens you need
to represent your problem. That doesn't
mean it's small amount of context. It
just means the least possible way to
represent your problem is the best way
to represent it.
>> Yeah.
Okay. So yeah, we had 30% of cloud code
users that were impacted and that's why
people were like oh this model is is you
know bad now
and I feel like this is happening with
every coding agent. Um maybe people get
used to it but in this case it was funny
cuz in the past people get used to the
model being good and they're like oh it
can't solve these problems anymore but
in this case it was literally the model
being worse.
So it's like no, it's actually just like
spewing garbage in in some cases.
>> Oh.
>> Um
>> Charles said something really
fascinating. The big models are all now
pure decoders and not encoders. I did
not know that. Uh I can't verify that.
If that is true, that is true. But I did
not know that.
>> Interesting.
>> Um Josh asked an interesting question
that I think we can come to in a second,
which is like is this really talking
about generation steps? Are we talking
about uh reading context inputs as
tokenizers? Uh
uh the tricky part here Josh is like
this stuff like every generation you
basically have to go read all the
previous tokens. So even if you add a
new tokens
um like once you generate messy you
still have to go do the same thing again
and then you have to generate the next
token. So I don't maybe I'm
misunderstanding the question but like
uh like for example word here might be
or might be the best word if someone
really if the model is trained to
believe that and now once messy
generated it basically behaves like all
the previous words and now you need to
move mechanisms around. So I'm not
understanding the question fully.
Um let's talk about the second one
output corruption. Um, these are just
bugs like this. There's nothing fancy
here. Just like at some point they just
had a they just had the they had a bug
in how they were assigning high
probabilities and like a random token
would just get high probabilities.
>> I think there's an underlying thing in
this whole article about GPU scarcity
and you'll see this from the first start
in the in the document where it says we
use three or four different providers
and different ways of like serving these
models. They use like AWS tranium. Um I
don't know if you scroll up all the way
by
uh all the way all the way. It literally
it says uh it's like on the next section
how we serve cloud code scale. Yeah. So
um yeah they have like Amazon bed raw
Google cloud vertex AI. So they're
spread across all these different
providers serving like cloud models and
then they have like AWS trainium etc.
Each of them has their own sort of
architecture. So they have to like
manage these at scale which is nuts. So
they are trying to squeeze every single
performance that they can in here. So
that just leads to bugs and uh at the
end of this article they said we
actually just stopped using these
performance optimizations because
quality is better than just having these
random bugs happen. Yeah, I can at least
say like I did a lot of high performance
work in the past and like every like we
did a lot of work where we take certain
parts of the algorithm and write in pure
assembly to make it really good and like
do a lot of SIMD work and that does
basically make the code what I call uh
write once read never. Uh it's actually
worse than readonly access. You can't
read it. You can only write to the file
because you can only mutate it um
because every other variant is
pointless. And I think what they're
doing here is run into very very similar
problems where the work here is just
like and the performance optimization
bug I think is kind of related to the
next thing that we'll talk about. Uh but
like basically like if they pick the
wrong token at the output you get total
nonsense.
>> Yeah I think this one
>> easier easier to detect for sure. It's
just like oh
>> nonsensical. I mean they just added some
detection for like unexpected
characters. I believe they just have
some other model that they train to be
like or like even some uristics that are
like hey if you're producing ASI and you
suddenly stop producing ASI or produce
some really esoteric ASI tokens
>> can you detect that and that's probably
an easy thing to go get
um I thought this one was actually the
where they spent the bulk of their time
and it's fascinating because like um
very interesting like compiler layer
misconfiguration that they had and it
this I think digs into a lot of various
topics
uh that I thought are um
almost how do I describe it very very
nuance so we'll see if this is
interesting to folks um and if it's not
too interesting we'll go we'll go faster
with the agent stuff if it is
interesting we'll talk more about it but
at a very very high level I kind of want
some people to have a good understanding
of how these top p sampling works and
how the models pick these tokens because
I think that fundamentally once you
understand that then you can understand
how these bugs can appear and how
complicated these systems are to go
build. So,
okay, we've talked about this in the
past. We're like, how does a model pick?
Well, once these tokens are done, how
does it actually pick this last token?
It goes through the whole uh transformer
architecture and at some point it spits
out a giant list of probabilities. It
spits out a probability for like every
single token you have. So, if you have
like a two million two million token
vocabulary, it basically spits out 2
million probabilities.
um down here. And when it spits out two
million probabilities, it basically says
that
sorry, oh sorry, I'm seeing the wrong
thing. When it spits out 2 million
probabilities, it basically says for
every single token in the token
vocabulary, what is the probability for
it given the sentence here? So if messy
is a token in the vocabulary, it will
tell you the probability of the word
messy in the sentence. If or is a word
in the vocabulary, it tell you the
probability of or. If M is a word, a
letter in the vocabulary and these all
are I think at least for opening eye.
>> Yeah.
>> The main point is also that you have all
this giant vocabulary and you're
actually trying to speed up inference.
>> Yes.
>> So you actually calculate these
probabilities in different chips
altogether
which um I just want to give people an
idea of what that means. So like in this
world if I wanted to generate messy
>> Oh, you can't I will pro Oh, I'm the
wrong screen. Whoops.
If I wanted to generate the word messy,
what I will end up having is I literally
have token probabilities for each of
these things. I'll have a token
probability for M, a token probability
for ME, token probability for ME, token
probability for MESS, and then and then
I messy is not a single token. So I will
not get that. So the whole point is when
these models are generating actual token
probabilities, I'm getting for every
single token along the way. And what I
really need to do,
>> oh yeah, zoom in more
>> over here is when I go generate these
tokens,
Aaron, can you help me write in here and
like get the M and the and the messy all
the way down. What I really need to do
here is somehow I need to go pick what
token I need to go pick. Uh what token
is going to go next? Because once I have
all those tokens, then I can decide
which is the best to go. And there's a
lot of valid candidates. Even if I want
to produce Messi, I could produce M and
then E SSI. I could produce me and then
SSI. I could produce mess and then a
separate token for I and all these are
valid ways to produce the right answer.
So even though it's a human we just see
the word messy to the model is actually
picking some other
uh it could pick many sequences and come
to the same conclusion of messy without
there being a right one. So all we get
are token probabilities. Now the problem
is how do you pick the best token
probability? Well model providers do a
variety of different things. What
Enthropic says that they do is they
actually cut they take the sum of all
tokens
that exist and they basically chop off
everything that falls below like a sum
of
0.99 or 99. And why do they do that?
Well, as many of you might have heard us
say before,
um, oh, let me zoom in even more. As
many of you might have heard before, uh,
floatingoint arithmetic is really,
really hard. So rather than dealing with
really really small values that are
completely nonlinear you just you just
say if I will take instead of adding up
to kilo sum of one which is what
everything should add up to after
softmax we'll take the probabilities
that add up to.99 and everything else we
just trash like nothing else matters.
So, if there's one token that adds up to
like 0.51 and another token that adds up
to 0 48, we'll take these two tokens and
nothing else. We'll just trash
everything else. Well, I guess
technically in this phase, we'll allow
we'll allow the any other tokens we take
up to take up to like 0.99.
And now we will only allow these tokens
in and every other token is ignored. And
that allows you to not get nonsense
characters by accident when you go do
this because what is temperature zero
doing? Well, temperature zero says given
all of these tokens, take the one with
the highest probability and basically
turn this into one. Oops.
And every other token probability
basically becomes
zero. You basically build a filter at
temperature zero that basically makes
everything else not matter. And all the
way at temperature one, we keep
everything to be the same probability.
And at temperature I think uh two, it
does some inverse distribution of it. So
it basically reduces the value of the
highest probability and makes it more
akin to uniform distribution.
>> Yeah. So they keep all these like
different hacks and stuff to uh account
for various um problems with like
floating point math, right? So in one
case in December 2024 in the article
they mentioned that
>> they had another bug that caused a
performance regression where the top
token was not chosen. So if we if you
were using cloud like for whatever
reason uh for whatever like task um I
would I would have expected the
performance to be like atrocious cuz
it's just not choosing that top token
ever.
>> Well sometimes it wasn't ever. I think
it was sometimes.
>> Oh I see.
>> But I want to describe one more element
of this like how does this 2 million
probability thing actually work? Cuz
like the problem is if you actually ever
toss this at a GPU and your token
vocabulary is large you can't actually
do this on a single GPU machine. So what
the further thing that makes this even
more complicated is not just that we
have to produce these token
probabilities and make it work. We have
to do this in a distributed manner. So
what you end up actually doing is you
end up saying that I don't actually know
if any token token vocabulary is
actually 2 million tokens. So just
please keep that in mind
>> but I don't actually know what the token
size is on that but I'm just using an
arbitrary number to describe the
vocabulary. I think like
what they will actually do is they will
actually run this in a batch process
where like machine one will basically
run token zero to like 32 thou,000 or
like technically like
32k.
Oops.
And then machine 2 will take the next 32
take tokens
64 uh and so on. And what ends up
happening now is now that you have
totally different token probabilities
being produced across different
machines, what you need to go do now is
how do you actually pick the top token?
Well, on each of these machines, you
need to go pick a relative top token. So
instead of saying instead of giving the
central machine every single token,
well, one way you could do it is you
could tell a central machine, here's all
my token probabilities and now pick the
best. Pick best from all. And that's one
way to do it. But an other mechanism
that is really useful is you ask every
machine what are your uh what candidates
do you want to propose
and if every m once and every machine
picks their provides their candidates so
not all of them but a subset of them
then you do a central uh pick max and
the bug that enthropic had in this
scenario was that they didn't actually
pick the candidate correctly from each
of these individual machines due to the
and we'll talk about what the real bug
was but what the bug led to was each of
these batches wasn't always picking the
right candidate and that led to the
right actual top global what I would
call the global top P not being
available or top token not being
available in the candidates array. So
then when you actually pick the best the
top token was just not missing. Now why
does this stuff happen? This stuff is
where it gets really really wild, at
least for me,
>> which is
>> Yeah,
>> it turns out
>> the code. Yeah, there we go.
>> It turns out Oh, this is the hack that
they did for actually like propagating
stuff down.
>> It turns out um we're back to
floatingoint precision. So what ended up
happening is they use 16 bit
floatingoint precision most of the time
but sometimes a TPU compiler optimized
using 32-bit optimization and it never
made a distinction of exactly when it
just did it sometimes.
And what that means is the way that they
were doing comparisons was really really
um
unlikely to be stable because for those
of you that have ever multiplied two
floatingoint numbers together like yeah
a time uh I have to go back here. I
can't type. Oops.
In floating point oh in floatingoint
math a * b * c
is not equal to
uh c * b * a like it it is very order
dependent. And now what ends up
happening is not only is this true, but
if you do f floating point 32 versions
of this one times
floating point a * b * c assuming
everything is a floatingoint 16 bit
integer instead of a 32-bit integer.
These are not guaranteed to be equal
even if the order is the same. And like
if you're curious about why this is
true, you can go into looking at how
floatingoint numbers are represented in
a very nonlinear way. And when you
multiply them, small numbers just don't
behave in the way that numbers,
>> we model numbers to behave in our heads.
>> So then what ends up happening
fundamentally is just you get a
comparison that said token A was uh like
token A was better than token B just
flipped because it was really close to
their boundary condition. It was like
40. It was like 0.59 versus like 0501
or 0509. And like you flip one
floatingoint operation and then which
one is better flipped. So then the
candidate that it this one suggested was
like this one instead of this one or
this one instead of this one because of
simple floatingoint uh maths around
this.
>> Yeah, I highly recommend this paper as
well from thinking machines that AJ has
uh shared. We won't go into detail on it
but uh it also talks about other causes
for nondeterminism
and uh it talks about how sometimes it's
not the floating point arithmetic but
like the batches that you run on the GPU
and how they are processed. Um but yeah
this is gets more like nitty-gritty into
the details.
>> Yeah, this is a really really good paper
for anyone that wants to go super deep
into it. Yeah,
>> but fundamentally I think the real
takeaway here is that like we're all
building these systems on top of systems
that we have even less control over in
any previous way we've had. So it's
really important to really be able to
quickly diagnose what are the areas of
the system that we want to go build. My
personal opinion is and Aaron I'd love
to know your thoughts on this but like a
big takeaway that I had from this is
like one sometimes the model did get
worse. Sometimes it's not in your head
and it did get worse. And any sort of
system you build needs to have some sort
of vibe check for you to have you need
some signal for you to really quickly
detect that this is actually happening
and you need to decide how actionable
that this is going to be. So in our in
in throic scenario they use Twitter and
I guess Aaron used Twitter or like other
verbal mentions of AWS to know if the
systems are down for a while
>> and as you guys build products you
probably want to build some sort of
indicator like that into your product
pipeline where you have like some lossy
signal that is really noisy
>> but it alone is not enough. I think the
interesting part is that for every
engineer that is new to the AI world in
this non-determinism world, you're used
to maybe working with distributed
systems where like distributed systems
are always in a constant state of
failure, right? That's why when you call
an HT when you do an HTTP request
anywhere, you should expect it to fail
at some point. So you can just expect to
have like a try catch or whatever of
some sort. with these models the failure
is like so subtle that we need new
mechanisms to observe these failures and
so observability is even more important
than before uh you just won't get an
maybe the endpoint itself like it's down
like whatever you get a 500 from the
entropic API but there could be other
bugs just related to the actual model
outputs that um you need to be able to
catch
>> yeah I think that's really and like
what's I think like anthropic highlights
that too is They're not going to stop
doing the Twitter analysis. Like that is
really good for them to know if things
are totally busted.
But I think one of the more things like
one you just add more inspection. I
don't think most people should do that
for their pipelines. It's too much work.
Like you should definitely unit test the
most important parts of the pipeline,
not the whole pipeline. Not worth it. Um
because enthropic is so widely used in
so many different scenarios and their
use case is different. They just need to
increase their eval pipeline. I think
for anyone that's doing bespoke
workflows, they don't need like hundreds
of eval. They just need to look at their
systems a lot more carefully. Like do
the do the stuff Enthropic did before
all this stuff. But I think one stuff
that is probably definitely shared that
everyone should do is this. You want
faster debugging tool. Like what Aaron
says like you really need to be able to
introspect your system as quickly as
possible because the minute a customer
reports an issue, you want to know one
of three things. Is it a is it really a
failure from the perspective of your
infrastructure? Is it a failure on the
perspective of your prompt? or is it a
failure from the perspective of like the
model?
>> And if you don't know which of those
three things is or if it takes you like
three hours to determine which which of
those three things it is,
>> like it's going to be hard for you as a
team.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. I'll close Discord. Uh
thank you for noting that. Uh my Discord
is running at all times.
um
it's going to be really really hard for
you as a team to make your system better
because your feedback loop is
fundamentally the only thing you have to
ship a really really good product.
>> Yeah, I think um in general you just go
a when you deploy stuff you should just
deploy like slowly like this is some
stuff that it's like the golden rule at
a AWS when I was at AWS like you don't
deploy worldwide at the same time. I
know a lot of people have startups and
they just like push to prod immediately.
If you can't help it, don't do that.
>> So, can I ask you a question? When do
you think someone should deploy to prod
or like like what how do you think about
this as a startup? Like we're a startup.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you think we should think about
this? Like should we roll out our
changes all the time?
>> You should. So, if you're a startup, you
don't have the bandwidth to like set up
all these like hosts and like, oh, you
have a one box deployment and then it
goes to all this stuff. And you could
also be running stuff in serverless. I
think using feature flags is a good way
to do it. Um where you can just kind of
like roll back instantly or deploy to
services that let you roll back
instantly. So for example, I don't know
if you're using Verscell, you can like
oneclick roll back in like two seconds,
right? So that's very helpful to to do
in these situations. Um and sometimes
when you're testing whether like it's a
prompt or is it a hallucination or is it
a model issue, the first thing you
should just do is roll back. That was
actually one of the slogans at AWS. It
was literally like, "Don't be a hero.
Roll back."
Like, you don't need to find out exactly
what it is and like patch a fix or
whatever. Like, don't ask questions.
Just roll it back. Who cares if you roll
it back to like the day before, it
doesn't matter.
>> Um,
>> actually really I like that framing.
>> I think that's actually the right way
for a lot of these AI pipelines. If your
system has been working for the last 3
weeks and suddenly you see like five
pings from users that have been using
your product already and expect it to
work,
>> something probably went wrong no matter
what it is.
>> If you roll back and you still see the
issue, then like maybe it is the model,
>> maybe it is maybe it is the
infrastructure,
>> right? Exactly. So if you roll back and
it's still broken, you know, you've
already eliminated one variable. So then
you can be like, "Oh, it's a model.
Let's let's switch models now. Let's
roll forward and switch to a different
model." But uh yeah uh I think
>> I want to talk about one more question
that I thought Josh asked brought up
that was fascinating.
>> Then we workflows.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you differentiate if it's a
failure or hallucination?
>> Um
>> what are your thoughts there?
>> Yeah. So if it's a failure or
hallucination
um
you can sort it depends on what task
you're trying to do like always like
senior engineer it depends. Um so for
example if you're like extracting data
from bank statements right and uh like
all of a sudden it hallucinated that the
sum is some different number you can
actually calculate this programmatically
and you can be like hey do all these
line items add up to the sum and if they
don't you know that there's a
hallucination. So there's like systems
you can build around LLMs and around
data extraction to make sure that it's
not hallucinating. But I know a lot of
cases are literally just like plain text
like qualitative data like it just spit
a sentence and you're not sure if it's
hallucinating. I think having customer
feedback is a really good uh start on
just like tell like having users tell
you if it's actually good or bad. And
you'll see this in literally every AI
product out there. There's like a thumbs
down or thumbs up button. And even
OpenAI is asking people to do thumbs. If
you cloud code,
>> if you've been pinged by cloud code,
whether it's good or bad, it's like, is
this good? Like they're asking people
constantly, like everyone. They're
asking literally everyone constantly all
the time if it's actually working. Um,
so you should do something similar in
your app.
>> I um I have a question about this. How I
guess like most people never click
thumbs up, thumbs down.
I don't know if
>> you how many times have you clicked it?
>> You only need a small subset of users.
And also like the
you'll click for example the the the
times where I do say it's not good is
when it's not good, right? When I'm
unhappy.
So I think what the most unhappy people
will always like kind of like try and
give you some sort of feedback.
>> I also uh on the topic of like is it a
failure or hallucination, I'll tell you
like one thing that I was thinking about
is like I think people don't really have
a good definition for hallucination. I
think it's a catch-all thing for like ah
something's not working and I'll tell
you why. Technically, if you define
hallucination as things that are not des
that are not backed by context you've
given it. Every time I ask a question
it's technically hallucinating. It
happens to align with how I perceive the
world and I I believe it. So I don't
classify it as such. And I think it's
really really hard to define that word.
So I think what the first thing I would
do is I would just go back to your
product and like be more concrete of
like what is is it factually incorrect
uh things where like I have cont I have
context that it is rejecting or not
taking advantage of is it because I'm
>> every time it disagrees with me I'm sure
it's a hallucination.
>> Yeah, exactly. Um so it's really hard to
go vibe that in my opinion of describing
hallucinations. That's like I would just
define that more concretely and then you
can know if it's a failure or
hallucation more clearly because a
failure is like the model is
of let me read Josh's thing but the
anthropic failure cause
um I think Josh I see I see which
question you're trying to ask now um
which is like in the case of enthropics
failure it's like the model is
inherently just picking not the model
enthropic is picking the wrong token
with their algorithm for selecting the
right token. So like how do you know
that that is going wrong versus your
prompting strategy?
Generally what I think here is like it's
really just about testing really fast.
You just if you if you build a gut model
for like hey the model the prompt isn't
working in the way you want it to work
and you have some business metrics that
you can tie to it. So like either users
are leaving more the chat threads are uh
either increasing or decreasing in like
number of messages exchanged depending
on what kind of application you're
building. Um what I would say is you
probably can build a proxy for like
product quality went down. Once you know
product quality went down then you can
figure out what went wrong. And what I
usually do in this scenario when a model
fails is yeah like if anthropic is not
working I usually just talk to the GD5
or the equivalent GPT model and I just
see is that one working cuz well usually
I stay with the same models and I bump
up to the bigger bigger model and then
after that if that is still not working
I actually don't spend too long on the
prop. I just swap to a different model
and a different model provider and if
that doesn't work then I do a little bit
of prompt engineering to see like oh
what can I do to actually make this work
and I think you kind of have to build
the right thing and it's really hard to
know if it's an actual infrastructure
and model failure. Um, John brought up
one interesting point of like, can we
not just set up experiments?
>> In theory, I think this is the promised
land that everyone wants, which is like
the promised land is like we have some
data set and then we run the data set
with a bunch of prompts and it tells us
good or bad and then we say yay.
>> In practice, I don't think it's that
easy because I don't I think most
problems don't have a definition of good
or bad.
>> How many of you have like a hundred
samples of your problem? How many of you
have built a hundred different test
cases for whatever prompt you have? I'm
sure that some have, but most people
probably haven't.
>> The magic number is 30.
>> Entropics error rate was8%.
So, they definitely need like a ton,
right? But this is Entropic. Obviously,
they have like thousands. Um, but if you
have maybe 1% of your users being
affected by something, like you just
need way more evals. Um, and you need
>> the thing is it's not like this is
another good question like the theory is
like wouldn't good eval. The problem
here isn't just like you want good eval.
The problem is you need evals that span
the distribution of the behavior your
users have.
>> So it's not it's quantity isn't the
thing and good is such a subjective term
it's hard to define. So I worked on Face
ID at Google. We have so many ta data
sets of people, the same person with
glasses, without glasses, with a
mustache, with a different haircut,
twins, siblings. You really need to
really quickly understand every
parameter. And I'll talk to you guys
something really weird. None of you
probably expect that face ID worked
worse in Phoenix. And actually, this is
true for a lot of things. A lot of
things work worse in Phoenix.
Anyone know why? Aaron, what's your
guess? Uh, well, you've already told me,
so
>> Oh, [ __ ] I told you. Uh, this is not as
fun. But for everyone else, um, it turns
out the temperature variation affects
how cameras calibrate in Phoenix because
it's so hot. In fact, a lot of things
get messed up because of how hot Phoenix
is.
>> Yeah. The materials expand this.
>> Exactly. So, the calibration you store
that tells you how how the camera is
perceiving the world is wrong. So now
your face ID is like it your face is
basically distorted and like a like a
funky mirror house. So it doesn't work
anymore. And you would never know that
if you didn't understand Face ID has
that thing that you have to go deal with
in Phoenix, Arizona. And if you've never
dealt with Phoenix, Arizona, you
probably would know and very sely
wouldn't predict that to happen.
>> Yeah. Um what Charles says is I think is
the best thing which is
>> you use real what you do is you ship
data to prod you collect that data and
you turn that into
>> you turn a subset of that into eval data
set that is the only answer
>> and that is a rolling it's not a onetime
task that is a thing that you do forever
because you have to constantly span how
your behavior is changing over time
>> exactly
um so yeah I think this is a good
summary
>> a fun think
uh TLDDR
>> do a quick
>> let's yeah I'll give a quick TDR and
let's talk about the other stuff that I
think I'm really I we'll see if we can I
can say a little over and we can keep
talking
>> um the TLDDR here is like
basically go and try and build a product
metric to your system build a really
really good debugging loop so it's not
hard for you to actually go and like
determine where the problem is and I
guess what Aaron says is don't be a hero
and roll back like go do that if you
need to.
>> Yeah.
>> Um cool. Let's talk about the next thing
which I thought was one of the most
interesting topics. Before I do that,
for anyone that's watching and is
interested, uh we do this uh
conversation every single Tuesday at 10
a.m. PST. It's uh myself, Aaron, and I
guess now Dexter as well. Uh it's called
AI that works. The whole point is to
talk about real in production scenarios.
Generally, we try and show some live
code along the way whenever possible.
Today's episode I thought was just like
more conceptually talking about some of
the work that Anthropic did that I
thought was relevant. So, no code today,
but we'll send out email summaries and
then we have all the blog post and
podcast recorded live. So, hopefully you
keep enjoying this content. Please give
us feedback about what we can do to make
it better along the way.
Um,
let's talk about uh the next thing, the
agent builder.
So open released some stuff.
>> Viva, why do you think everyone is
building these? 11 Labs literally
released their own agent building
builder.
>> So do you want to screen share and talk
about your what we're talking about
first?
>> Just so everyone knows. And let's catch
everyone up.
>> Yeah. One sec.
>> While you pull that up, how often should
you run evals in prod? Um daily, weekly?
Honestly, depends on your use case. Uh
there's no specific um there's no global
answer for this.
>> Yeah. So, here's one agent builder. Uh,
I don't know if this will actually play
anything. Oh, yeah. This kind of stuff,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, you have a start, you hand off to an
agent, there's a conversation, etc. Um,
this is
>> like we've all seen this in like NAD,
but like OpenI released one too, I
think, recently, right? Yeah, there's n
there's open AI agent
builder.
>> Yeah. Agent kit or whatever they called
it.
>> Yeah. So there
>> and you want to zoom in on that image.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um many of you might have seen
this like open releases thing. They
released prompt optimizers a bunch of
other things.
>> We just had a fun conversation about it.
What are your thoughts, Aaron? Um, so
one I think I think this is just like a
push to have nontechnical users build
these agent workflows, right? Because
code is scary, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Which is also interesting because code
is easier for people to write now
because you can just write a prompt and
like it'll write a bunch of code. But I
think if you're in this kind of closed
environment where hey, you can just drag
and drop these nodes and build
something, it makes it more manageable
and less scary. Um, another big part of
this is just like integrations. So maybe
there's a node that allows you to like
integrate your Google Docs or Google
Drive and you can just create a little
workflow and like boom, everything is
kind of working. Um,
>> I think one thing that I think that
integration point is under super
undervalued because like if I'm a
non-technical user, think about how hard
it would be even if I had to use cloud
code or something and I can magically
vibe code to say that in the end I want
you to produce a Google doc as an
artifact because Google doc is a thing
I'm used to or PDF is a output that I'm
used to. And I think what's really
useful there is it's something I don't
have to think about anymore. It's like I
just draw a little line to a thing that
says write a Google Drive file and it
mostly works. Now the problem is the
minute I realize that I actually need
like very specific folder names and all
the other stuff then you're like oh
shoot I'm basically writing code in the
UI builder.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think it's like
>> are you still screen sharing?
>> Yeah, I am screen sharing this. So this
is an interesting part. So you you start
out building these agent builders but
eventually you're going to need
structure outputs, right?
>> Yeah. Because you the way to to have
unstructured data like a user's message
talk to your actual program and logic uh
to do that you need to transform
unstructured data to structured data.
You need a schema. So whenever you start
designing your schema, that's where the
problem begins with a lot of these agent
workflow UIs because like just take a
look at this. Like, oh my god. Like,
imagine someone trying to explain to you
their their schema and not having then
you use these outputs in like other
fields and like you don't have type
safety and all that kind of stuff and
it's just like oh my god it this is it's
>> I think it's really interesting though
cuz like while this part is super
horrific here if you go back to the
other one version
>> that is really beautiful
>> like I look at that and I'm like that is
high and I can see why openi did this
because they're like
Like lovable is out here making people
make a lot of money and like why does
lovable need to make that money? We can
make that money.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And like you can imagine OpenAI
says why don't you just write a box here
on this box that says this is a prompt
and we'll generate some code that meets
that prompt under the hood and they just
do the codegen over there with GPD
codeex or something and it spits
something out. But I think the point
that you're making here is like while
this is really easy with a true and
false thing for it to go read and a
human can go figure out like roughly
what's happening here.
>> Mhm.
>> The more complex this gets like think
about what what is a function? Like a
lot of us on listen on the call are all
engineers. A function is basically a
repeatable version of a block here
um that basically you repeat two times
because like two other places use it.
merely a readability artifact because
technically you could just like
duplicate the code over and over again.
But one thing I'm always confused about
these agent builders is how do you build
a function? Like how do I build a
repeatable unit of work that I can reuse
over and over again? And that's and I
know that they have some sort of
composition stuff that you can go do but
the ergonomics of that are something I'm
always fascinated about like how do you
go do that?
>> The other interesting part about this is
uh the naming of it. So, it's agent kit.
But, uh, and then here you have like a
workflow with some agents as well
interled.
>> I thought that was cool.
>> Yeah, it's cool. Um, and in this case, I
mean, the these agents are probably
doing like a bunch of stuff or maybe
just a prompt.
>> Let me ask you as a founder.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, as a founder when you see this and
you see literally every company in the
world releasing this.
>> Yeah.
>> What's the alpha here?
>> Like what company has alpha in building
this? Cuz like I think this isn't like a
dead space. It seems somewhat useful. I
mean, OpenAI said they spent six weeks
to build this, right? Um,
>> okay. So,
>> that's literally what they said. They
they spent six weeks, they just launched
this. Uh, they use codecs to build it.
So, there's really no mode right now in
like just building these.
>> But what is the mode though?
>> These AI uh I think for for OpenAI is
just the integrations with their
existing models. Like for example, they
could have a model that's only usable in
this platform.
>> Oh,
>> that you can't use.
>> That is interesting.
>> And actually that's what they did with
Codex initially. Like Codex was not
available in cursor. You had to download
the codec CLI and then many days later
it was available in cursor. But that's
kind of how you start building some sort
of mode. The responses API is also a way
to build mode. Why? Because it's just so
different from the chat completions API.
and uh they can just own more of the
agentic loop. I think it's a better
design API to be honest. Uh but it is
another way that you start building some
modes.
>> That is true because now if someone uses
a responses API, they need to conform to
like supporting web search and all those
other stuff that OpenAI now supports
that people work.
>> Exly. It's like how will that even work?
If I switch every time you use a model
specific tool, by the way, you're
basically entrenching yourself into that
provider's mode,
>> which is not necessarily a bad it's kind
of what happened with CL with cloud,
right? It's like I think Terraform was
kind of this aspirational world in which
like hey we don't need to care about
cloud specific and like for some stuff
that is true but it turned out like at
some scale like the cost of moving
between clouds is so like the cost of
moving between clouds is so so hard.
>> Yeah.
>> That you would never actually do that.
>> Yeah. Like AWS works pretty well. Um
people use it and they're like yeah
screw this. Like I'll just I'll just be
in AWS. doesn't matter if they have a
service that's only
>> and then the value of like Terraform
goes down a little bit because it's not
as useful because you just use ads CDK.
>> Yeah.
>> And like what I wonder is in this model
world how does that pan out? My at least
my thoughts and obviously I'm biased and
I'm sure you are too and I'm everyone
knows that
>> like I feel like the model itself is
doing inference. The inference part is
probably the least interesting and
unique part now of building most
pipelines.
>> Mhm. I really think it's about how it
composes with the rest of your stack
where the value is.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think um
>> and like this lets OpenAI kind of
explore that version of the stack.
>> Yeah. But like you're saying how does
this plug into your existing code or
>> maybe it doesn't need to cuz you're like
Zapier is like makes money and like
maybe this is just like kill Zapier. I'm
like yeah screw it.
I think it's very hard for
right now a single provider to take like
everything. It's just like the winds of
intelligence change all the time. Like
there's like yesterday it's cloud,
tomorrow it's codeex that there there's
like no um loyalty to any of these
providers and there's still a lot of
room to build something that works with
anything in my view.
>> I think so.
So yeah, I think uh it's an interesting
concept. I think it definitely helps a
lot of people that are nontechnical and
we'll see what kind of things people
build, but I have seen some complicated
pipelines and this kind of UI just does
not work if if you have more than like
maybe 10 15 notes here. You're just like
what is happening? Um so yeah, sure.
>> Well, yeah. And like maybe there's
enough workflows in the future that are
really really simple and it's okay.
>> Yeah, I agree.
Um, well, with that, we'll take a couple
more questions if people have some
questions about any topic while we're
on.
>> Um, but otherwise, we'll probably close
it out here and then talk about
interesting things.
>> Erin, what was your first thoughts? Uh,
back to your live streaming days.
>> Back to my live streaming days. Um,
dude, it's all good. All good.
Let's see. Um, see what models. What do
we have in the chat?
Cool. Um
>> yeah, I think that's it for now.
>> Uh yes, there's this interesting do we
use Dex? So Dexter should talk about a
research plan implement workflow that we
used in the past. Um I I think we can
both give our perspective on it and see
how well it works. Um my perspective is
I have found that it is useful for
really really hard tasks when I want to
go do it, but for easy tasks it
sometimes feels like more overhead. It's
like I think it's like any process that
you do as a software engineer. It's like
any amount of process I hate and I will
do the minimum amount of process I need
to to get the outcome I want. So like
when I was at Google I freaking hated
writing some design docs because I was
like why do we have to write a PRD then
a design doc and then go ship it like
when we all know what the right answer
is. We've all talked about this before.
We know the algorithm. Let's go and do
it. And sometimes it's like holy cow's a
really ambiguous problem. there's like
seven different things that this might
touch that we that many of us aren't
familiar with and the process of writing
the doc is useful. What about you Aaron?
>> Um so for me in um in the research plan
implements I I have like my own
template. I haven't used like Dex's one
specifically, but I do go through like
the approach of like, hey, create a
markdown doc, like let's review it
together, and then after it's done in a
good way, then I'll start like coding.
Um, and then go from there. And if I
don't like it, I'll just redo the whole
thing. It's funny because we were
talking about this and there was a tweet
about this where someone was like, "It's
funny that I can literally just have
like when I see a PR, if I don't like
something, I can just ask the LLM to
like redo the whole thing. Even if it's
like a thousand lines of code, it's just
like redo the whole thing. I don't like
this approach." But if it's a human's
PR, you can't really do that because
they'll get mad at you. So, you kind of
just have to push the code and like live
with that forever.
and you can push hard and like redo it,
but at some point there's like a
limitation of like the human limitation
of just like how people feel about their
code. Um, so I thought that was
interesting.
>> What stuff are you using to write code
now?
>> Um, me myself, I'm using um Claude a
bunch set for 4.5. I think I'm like
flying with that. And then sometimes for
like tricky problems, I do fall back to
like Codex Codex CLI. But I do feel
>> why not use Codex all the time?
>> Uh it just takes too long. It just takes
too long thinking through things. Um I
feel like I just go faster with Claude
and
>> I get similar
similar outputs in a way.
>> The other thing that I've noticed Aaron
does um I don't know I don't know if you
noticed this is like we have a Slack
channel where he added a bunch of uh
where we added a bunch of uh what's it
called? coding bots to it
>> and we just keep tagging cursor or like
claw in it with like random tickets
>> and we don't actually like consider it.
We just look at it. We're like, "Oh, did
this one actually work?" Cool. We'll
merge it and we'll go read that code.
It's like almost like we burn tokens for
an opportunity cost of it might solve
the issue.
>> And if it does, great. If it doesn't,
trash it.
>> Yeah, it is interesting that there is an
overhead though of doing that where like
now we have to go back into all these
PRs. If you go to our repo, there's like
a bunch of pers that are open that are
like just like stranded in there that we
need to triage um because we still need
to test them out.
>> Cool.
>> I that's an interesting question. Are
people saving BAML to databases and
allowing users to edit and update BML
code? We have a type called dynamic type
in BAML which a lot of people do use
like we have where they can control
parts of the schema. We also do have a
way to run BAML dynamically. I know one
team that does that. Most people just
use Titebuilder and the dynamic
interface around it.
>> Yeah.
>> That said, we've been thinking about
this because like I think the world of
software is really changing cuz like you
do want not like the UI builders are so
fascinating cuz like non-engineers can
actually engineer.
>> Yeah.
>> But I think what we really want to live
in is in a world where like our
engineers write kind of like the
contracts that we want to abide by and
we want our non-engineers to be able to
edit all the stuff but the contracts. In
some ways, the type system is like the
contract. So, our engineers define the
type system and what if like
non-engineers could edit everything but
the type system. I think that's a really
fascinating perspective that we've been
thinking about.
>> Yeah. Uh, all right. I think it's uh
about time.
>> Yeah, we should head out. Um, but
everyone, thank you for joining. Uh,
we're going to have a another u session
next week. I think next week is going to
be a fun one. Dex and I have been
planning. It's going to be about
actually like live coding. We're going
to vibe code a new feature from scratch
in the BAML project using Texas's
approach. So, it'll be a slightly longer
session, three to four hours, and you'll
literally watch us code on the fly and
just see how we collaborate and get
stuff done. Um, but really looking
forward to stuff is fun. Check us out.
Uh, you can sign up over here for the
next event and always join the discord
for the human boundary and all the links
should be in the email and the post
notes that we submit.
>> All right.
>> All right, everyone. Thanks for coming.
Thanks for joining.
>> Bye.